this has been our first interview too
this is really fun oh my God y are the
best I could talk to you forever so
happy we're doing you it's just like I
don't know it's really heartwarming it's
giving me so much um Faith it's like you
know um I'm going to out you guys for a
second for being the cutest when I
having a baby shower was really hard for
me cuz it's weird to get attention
around something that's not being a
performer like when you guys get married
it's going to feel weird yeah cuz you're
kind of like like why is everyone so
happy for me I haven't made you know I
haven't like earned this or something
you guys came with the baby shower it
made so like so much to me and everyone
I mean my you know our friends are
animals like they want nothing more than
to just say horrible things about people
and they were just like they are the
cutest